e tem um sapo no interior te chamo tu
passa no gol
e tem uns que parece eu jogando bola
assim perto do
e não tem silêncio na casa da minha mãe
é no meio da cidade do lado de cá uma
igreja católica do radical Igreja
Evangélica 7:00 começa daqui 9:00 começa
aqui eu gosto de dormir quando eu vou
pro interior 8:00 que eu quero tipo
regular o relógio para ver se eu acordo
cedo curto o dia
7:00 começa a mulher daqui cantar que eu
não sei se ela que canta assim uma
microfone que fabrica ó ó
na
nossa Chega logo e não chega não cair
passa um tempo a dica começa ele tá aqui
tá aqui ó e o
que hora que eu vou dormir eu durmo
quando aqui da meia hora que ela grita
só
[Música]